what i want to do in this video is
familiarize ourselves with a a very
common class of sequences and this is
arithmetic
arithmetic sequences and they're usually
pretty easy to spot they're sequences
where each term is a fixed number larger
than the term before it so my goal here
is to figure out which of these
sequences are arithmetic sequences and
then just so that we have some practice
with some of the sequence notation i
want to define them in
either as explicit functions of the term
you're looking for the index you're
looking at or as recursive definitions
so first given that an arithmetic
sequence is one where each successive
term is a fixed amount larger than the
previous one which of these are
arithmetic sequences
well let's look at this first one right
over here to go from negative 5 to
negative 3
we had to add 2
then to go from negative 3 to negative 1
you have to add 2. then to go from
negative 1 to 1 you had to add 2. so
this is clearly an arithmetic sequence
we're adding the same amount every time
and there's several ways that we could
define the sequence we could say it's
a sub n and you don't always have to use
k this time i'll use n to denote our
index from n equals 1 to infinity with
and there's two ways we can define it we
could either define it explicitly or we
could define it recursively so if we
wanted to define it explicitly we could
write a sub n is equal to whatever the
first term is in this case our first
term is negative five
it's equal to negative five
plus we're going to add two
one less times than the term we're at so
for the second term we add two once for
the third term we add two twice for the
third for the fourth term we added from
our base term we added two three times
so we're going to add two we're going to
add positive two
1 less than the index that we're looking
at n
minus 1 times so this is an explicit
definition of this arithmetic sequence
if i wanted to write it recursively i
could say
a sub 1 is equal to
negative 5
and then each successive term for a sub
2 and greater so i could say a sub n
is equal to a sub n minus 1
plus 3. each term is equal to the
previous term plus or not 3 plus 2.
so this is for
for n
greater than or equal to 2. so either of
these either of these are completely
legitimate ways of defining of defining
the arithmetic sequence that we have
here we can either define it explicitly
or we could define it recursively
now let's look at this sequence is this
one arithmetic
well we're going from hundred we add
seven
107 to 114 we're adding 714 to 121 we
are adding seven so this is indeed an
arithmetic sequence so just to be clear
this is one
and this is one right over here and we
could write that this is the sequence a
sub n
and going from 1 to infinity
of and we could just say a sub n if we
wanted to find it explicitly is equal to
plus we're adding seven every time
and then each term the second term we
added seven once third term we add seven
twice so for the nth term we're going to
add seven n
minus 1 times so this is an explicit
definition of it but we could also do it
recursively we could also say
we could also so just to be clear this
this is one definition where we write it
like this
we write it like this or we could write
a sub n
from n equals 1 to infinity in either
case i should write with
with
and if i wanted to find it recursively i
could say a sub 1 is equal to 100
and then for a sub n
for anything larger than one for any
index above one a sub n is equal to the
previous term
plus
plus seven and one so we're done this is
another way of defining it so in general
if you wanted a generalizable way to
spot or define an arithmetic sequence
you could say
an arithmetic sequence is going to be of
the form
a sub n if we're talking about an
infinite one from n equals 1 to infinity
if you wanted to find it explicitly you
could say a sub n is equal to
is equal to some constant which would
essentially be the first term
it would be some constant plus
plus
some
number that you're incrementing or i
guess this could be a negative number or
decrementing by times n minus one so
this is one way to define an arithmetic
sequence in this case d
was two in this case d is seven that's
how much you're adding by each time and
in this case k is negative five and in
this case k is one hundred the other way
that you could just if you wanted to
write the recursive way of defining an
arithmetic sequence generally you could
say
a sub 1 is equal to k
and then a sub n is equal to a sub n
minus 1. a given term is equal to the
previous term plus d
for n greater than or equal to 2. so
once again this is explicit this is the
recursive way of defining it and we
would just write with there now the last
question i have is is this one right
over here an arithmetic sequence
well let's check it out
to start we start at 1 then we add 2
then we add three so this is immediate
giveaway this is not an arithmetic
sequence now we are adding four we're
adding a different amount every time so
how could we so this first of all not
this is not arithmetic
this is not an arithmetic sequence but
how could we define this since we're in
where we're trying to define our
sequences
so if we wanted to define it if we
wanted to define it let's say let's we
wanted to define it recursively so this
could we could say this is
equal to
a sub n
where n is starting at 1 and it's going
to infinity
with
with we'll we'll say our base case a sub
1 is equal to 1
and then for n is 2 or greater a sub n
is going to be equal to what so a sub 2
is the previous term
plus 2 a sub 3 is the previous term plus
3 a sub 4 is the previous term plus four
so it's going to be the previous term
it's going to be the previous term plus
whatever your index is plus whatever
your index is so this looks close but
notice here we're changing the amount
that we're adding based on what our
index is we're adding the amount of
index to the previous term and so this
is 4
n is greater than or equal to 2. well
for an arithmetic sequence we're adding
the same amount regardless regardless of
what our index is here we're adding the
index itself so this one is not
arithmetic but it's an interesting
sequence nonetheless